Darth Vader reigns supreme as
the greatest bad guy the Star
Wars franchise has ever seen. That
being said, here are some franchise
villains who are arguably even scarier
and more powerful than Vader himself.
When discussing iconic villains outside of the
core Star Wars movies, one has to mention Grand
Admiral Thrawn. The stoic Chiss strategist
helped resurrect Star Wars in the 1990s, with
Timothy Zahn's beloved Heir to the Empire novels
jump-starting interest in the franchise again.
"Where is your master? Where
is Grand Admiral Thrawn?"
Though he was briefly expunged from the
canon after Disney took over the franchise,
Thrawn returned in Star Wars Rebels and has become
increasingly important to the modern timeline.
He's the primary villain of the live-action
Ahsoka on Disney+, and for good reason.
Thrawn is a truly terrifying individual.
Sure, he may not have the hulking black suit,
murderous Force powers, or imposing red lightsaber
Darth Vader has, but in a way, that only makes him
more intimidating. Aside from his bright red eyes
and cold blue skin, he looks pretty normal. But
that unassuming exterior hides one of the most
brilliant and brutal minds in all of Star Wars.
Though he occasionally hesitates before taking
innocent lives, Thrawn is usually willing to
do anything necessary to win. And his Legends
incarnation is even more frightening than the
new canon Thrawn, though Disney still has a
lot of places it could take the character.
Stepping back into the modern Star Wars canon,
we've got the shadowy leader of the Nightsisters
of Dathomir, Mother Talzin. Talzin primarily
appears as a secondary antagonist in Star Wars:
The Clone Wars, where she aids
her "children" Asajj Ventress,
Savage Opress, and Maul in their battles
against Darth Sidious and Count Dooku.
She puts a lot of innocent people in danger
through her dark Force schemes of conquest.
"I must make the necessary preparations."
Talzin may not be as overtly intimidating
or good in a fight as Darth Vader or many
other characters on this list. However, she
makes the cut for slightly different reasons.
Even though she hasn’t attempted
to take over the Galactic Senate,
her Force powers are beyond
almost anyone else in the canon.
Talzin's magical abilities are never fully
explained, which is also what makes them
so dangerous. Throughout The Clone Wars, she
demonstrates a mastery of the dark arts that
allows for full mind control, the ability
to cheat death through spiritual means,
and the power to turn other life forms
into incredibly powerful and violent
soldiers. Darth Sidious considers her a
direct rival, and he goes out of his way
to deal with her in The Clone Wars after
her interference in his plans. If you've
got Sheev knocking on your front door, you know
you're doing something right – or, well, wrong.
Though villains like Revan and Nihilus may be more
famous than The Old Republic foe Darth Malgus,
their stories are also more complicated,
which is part of their appeal. Malgus,
on the other hand, is a villain
in every sense of the word.
"Finally, we have returned."
A brutal tactician and fearsome warrior, Malgus
wrote the playbook Darth Vader uses when he
sacks the Jedi Temple at the end of the Clone
Wars. Malgus took over the stronghold several
thousand years earlier, wiping out numerous Jedi
masters and effectively shattering the order.
Malgus was a force in the galaxy for years,
putting Jedi and fellow Sith alike in
their place and establishing himself as
a dark Force boogeyman. Plus, just
look at the guy. He's terrifying!
Some of the characters on this list
are beings of pure dark Force energy,
leaders of powerful military legions,
and ruthless murderers. Dagan Gera is
none of those things. He's a former Jedi whose
obsession and ego lead him down a dark path,
eventually forgoing everything and
everyone he once claimed to fight for.
"How arrogant that you would
presume to know what drives me!"
When you first meet Dagan Gera
in Star Wars Jedi: Survivor,
it's not unusual to just feel bad for
the guy. During the High Republic era,
hundreds of years before the original Star
Wars trilogy, Dagan was one of the order's
most powerful and respected knights. In the
time since he was put into stasis, the entire
Jedi Order was destroyed. However, these initial
feelings of sympathy are quickly replaced by fear.
Dagan may not have the warlord persona of Darth
Vader, but it's hard to watch him in motion and
not feel unnerved. He looks, walks, and
talks like a ghost — a clear reflection
of his status as a man out of time. His icy
eyes and cold, determined energy are imposing,
to say the least, and that's without even
getting into Dagan's power as a fighter.
He pushes Cal Kestis to his limit with
only one arm, and his skill at projecting
illusions through the Force is beyond
anything previously seen in the canon.
The dark side is more than just a cool
goth aesthetic, but nobody told The Son
that. He's also crazy powerful: as one
of the three Force Wielders of Mortis,
also known simply as "The Ones," The Son
is an ancient being of immense power whose
very essence is intrinsically connected to
the Force. And while his sister got to be
part of the light side, The Son — through no
choice of his own — was stuck with the dark.
"How simple you make it. Light and dark,
as if there is one without the other."
The Mortis arc of Star Wars: The Clone
Wars shows just how terrifying The Son
can be. Not only is he an incredibly
powerful Force user in his own right,
capable of high-level combat abilities and
full-on transformation into a massive beast,
but he can take over the minds of other people
and twist them toward the dark. His father
suggests that The Son escaping from Mortis
could doom the entire galaxy. Fortunately,
Anakin, Obi-Wan, and Ahsoka Tano manage
to stop the Son before that happens.
Star Wars Knights of the Old Republic II: The
Sith Lords introduced several great characters,
including the dark Sith Lord Darth Traya.
"There will always be a Darth Traya.
The galaxy needs its betrayers."
What sets Traya apart from the other Sith on this
list, and even from her one-time allies Darth Sion
and Darth Nihilus, is her utter disdain for the
Force itself. Traya views the Force as a god of
sorts — one that forces its will on every being
in the galaxy, trapping them in its eternal plan.
For this reason, she wants to free the galaxy from
its influence — something that no other villain in
all of Star Wars has ever attempted. The sheer
scale of Traya's scheme puts her in a class by
herself — a harbinger of destruction who truly
believes that her way is the best for the galaxy.
We'd be remiss not to include a villain from the
Star Wars High Republic era on this list, and the
obvious choice is Marchion Ro. The leader of the
deadly marauder band known as the Nihil, Marchion
Ro is directly responsible for causing the
so-called "Great Hyperspace Disaster," which kicks
off the High Republic arc and leads to widespread
destruction and death across the galaxy.
Though he's ostensibly just a pirate, Ro devises a
plan that puts the Jedi on the back foot. His most
terrifying weapons are the Nameless, ruthless
monsters who hunt down anyone strong in the
Force. Quite literally boogeymen for the Jedi,
the Nameless are used to great effect during
Marchion Ro's conquests. He can't Force-choke
you or shoot lightning out of his hands,
but he shows just how powerful someone can become
simply through strategy, determination, and fear.
Ro causes more chaos than most Sith Lords ever
have, earning him an easy spot on this list.
In both Legends and the modern Star
Wars canon, Darth Bane is the creator
of the "Rule of Two" — the Sith doctrine that
dictates there can only be one master and one
apprentice of the order at any given time.
Roughly 1,000 years before the prequels,
the Sith were wiped out by a combination of
their war with the Jedi, constant infighting,
and Bane's efforts to eradicate them from within.
Prior to Bane instituting the Rule of Two,
the Sith were a sprawling order much like the
Jedi. He believed that the only way for them
to be strong enough to survive was to consolidate
power in as few people as possible. The rule was
designed from the beginning with this goal in
mind: a master to wield the full brunt of the
dark side and an apprentice to keep the master
on their toes. The inherent tension between the
two would ensure that the most powerful
person possible would always be on top.
His importance to the history of Star Wars is
enough to land him on a list of notable villains,
but Bane is intimidating enough in his own
right to earn a spot here. Plenty of Sith
have wiped out innocents and Jedi, but Bane
seemingly wiped out the rest of the Sith,
proving himself a true villain among villains.
Born Jacen Solo, the son of Han and Leia,
Darth Caedus is one of the most famous and
powerful villains in the Legends timeline.
He fights valiantly in the Yuuzhan Vong War
but never truly recovers from the loss
of his younger brother, Anakin Solo,
or the torture he suffers during the war. Jacen's
fall to the dark side is one of the longest,
most fully developed storylines in the entire
Expanded Universe, culminating in a tragic climax.
Darth Caedus is downright terrifying and
one of the most powerful Force users in
all of Star Wars. Few characters are ever
able to match him in a lightsaber duel,
and even his uncle Luke Skywalker, at the height
of his powers, struggles immensely to defeat him.
His Force powers are among the most outrageous
in the history of the franchise: Caedus learns
to ignore all pain, and at one point, even
becomes one with the Force while still alive.
Darth Krayt certainly isn't the most famous
villain from the Star Wars Legends timeline.
But in a way, he's the most important
villain in the entire Expanded Universe.
Krayt's journey starts the
way so many Sith stories do:
being trained as a Jedi. Under his birth name
of A'Sharad Hett, he was a young member of the
order during the prequel era and fought
alongside Anakin Skywalker in the Clone
Wars. But it's not until decades later that
he becomes a proper player in the story.
A series of Sith encounters and brutal clashes
with the Yuuzhan Vong lead Krayt down a path
to the dark side. He becomes the leader of a
secret Sith sect, briefly emerges to help Luke
Skywalker defeat Abeloth, but then goes back
into hiding. Through various bouts of stasis
and a literal death and resurrection arc, Krayt
lives far into the future, eventually crossing
lightsabers with Luke and Anakin's distant
descendant Cade Skywalker during the Star Wars:
Legacy series. Beyond all that, Krayt is a true
master of the Force and one of the main reasons
that Jacen Solo turns to the dark side. Even Luke
Skywalker comes to fear the so-called "Dark Man."
It's kind of cheating to put two different
characters in the same spot on this list,
but there's a good reason for it. To
be honest, the Yuuzhan Vong as a whole
species could have their own ranking
here. In the entirety of Star Wars,
there may not be a more horrifying foe. But
in the interest of keeping things specific,
we're focusing on two particular Yuuzhan Vong —
Shimrra Jamaane, the Supreme Overlord during the
Yuuzhan Vong War, and Onimi, who's pulling
the strings of the war from the shadows.
In a way, these two characters are the same.
Shimrra is the face, and Onimi is the mind.
The plan to invade the Star Wars galaxy and
assimilate it into the Vong's distorted,
biohacked hellscape comes from Onimi, and the
many warriors of these zealous conquerors put it
into practice. The Yuuzhan Vong War is the single
most devastating event in the Expanded Universe,
wiping out countless lives and numerous beloved
characters, including Chewbacca and Anakin Solo.
The Vong are horrifying to look at, they use
torture as a standard method of breaking and
corrupting prisoners, and with only a couple of
exceptions, like Onimi, they have absolutely zero
connection to the Force. And no two Vong are more
scary or powerful than Onimi and Shimrra Jamaane.